this winter they're enjoying the action
at the Olympics this summer they're back
in theaters for their next adventure
Disney Pixar's Incredibles 2 in theaters
June 15 and don't miss a special look
during Olympics coverage Wednesday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you have
[Music]
iconic she's an artist she is the
history of fashion like no other
designer she's a legend modern graphic
and power ridiculous she's a visionary
I'm talking about obviously I first
encountered Edna's work I remember
sitting in Paris it was Paris Couture
Week more statistics II didn't wanna
show the Chanel do me gasps you animal
and here comes Edna explosive jumpsuit
and no moth collection with such a piece
buddy - it's like no one else unlike
anything I had ever seen when she
designed a dress for me for the Emmys
and I knew that I've made it as a model
supermodels some show and prey darling
Mila it's like elincia
Louis Vuitton Edna she's a visionary a
giant I mean well not literally she
comes up to my knees hmm my favorite add
new piece the nuclear onesie the
bulletproof romper the rocket stilettos
it's outrageous everyone has their the
Beast and they can't all pull it off
simple elegant yet oh she's very
intimidating no Kate no cape no kiss no
comment Edna hate escapes so we all hate
capes have you ever heard anything so
ludicrous Edna's a divisive figure but
at the end of the day she's a visionary
I would say Edna mode is like the
modern-day Andy Warhol but I think Andy
Warhol looked up to her bravo Bravo
darling
Thank You Edna you're the best of the
best
No um they said I was gonna get an Edna
piece because I did the interview
you